Mr. Prime Minister,
apparently,
we need to hurry up a bit
because you still have to go to davaos.
Well, that's not the reality,
uh,
it's with the millionaires out there.
You will still take the time to free us,
uh, 5 minutes,
because the reality
of millionaires in davaos is obviously not the
reality of the working class in Europe.
Today, your
government takes the lead of a Europe in 1
social situation
catastrophic.
Wages are no longer enough,
people are afraid of groceries,
fear of turning up the heat,
even when it is cold like today.
And there anyway,
extremely striking that in this context,
you do not dare in your speech,
not assume
central priority of this Belgian presidency
which is the return of the budget rules
that you keep quiet,
which is well present in the document,
in the plan,
but which is here in your speech,
you hide the return of European laws.
Of osterity,
What does that mean?
It's going to tell you cuts,
budget cuts in hospitals,
in schools,
in the day care centers,
and even because there,
in deux-mille-vingt-trois,
the European Commission,
it's already full of indexing
wages in Belgium.
Even our salaries are likely to be
attacked with this mechanism.
So,
do you really want to be the
government, fangs,
who will bring back this straitjacket
And who will put the rope around the neck of the people
everywhere in Europe ?
We must not bring back this straitjacket,
you have to.
Bury it and,
as president,
sabotage its negotiations,
stop its negotiations on the budget pact.
And rather than cut our salaries,
in our services.
Mr. Profit,
read yesterday's ex-wife report.
Multinationals,
all over the world,
in Europe too,
make overprofits to pulverize
all the records in deux-mille-vingt-trois.
And yet,
no initiative
ambitious for a fairer taxation in your
program, none,
1 minimum ambition,
please,
Tax, uh,
millionaires,
large multinationals
or financial transactions.
What you are afraid to do?
Because after,
Bill Gates
will not go to the Belgian Senate later
in Davos. Frankly,
it is not from this europe
that workers need.